Though Rick Riordan's Percy Jackson series
is intended for younger audiences, there's
quite a bit for more seasoned viewers to pick
up on.
From mythological mistakes to surprising musical
references, here are the things in the Percy
Jackson movies that only adults would find
unobscured by the Mist.
For a movie based entirely around Greek mythology,
The Lightning Thief doesn't always pay as
much attention to its source material as it
should.
We could forgive a few approximations and
omissions here and there, but there's one
glaring inconsistency that undermines the
entire plot of the film.
Persephone shouldn't have even been in the
Underworld when Percy and his friends arrived
there around the summer solstice.
According to her own mythology, she's forced
to remain in her husband's domain during the
winter months.
In the spring and summer months, she brings
mild weather to the Earth above.
In fact, the entire quest for the pearls,
which takes up the bulk of the film, is inspired
by Persephone's captivity in the Underworld,
as the pearls belong to her and allow the
user to travel to and from Hell.
The movie references her imprisonment frequently
but neglects to portray it accurately.
It might not have been so big of an issue
if it wasn't Persephone who ended up securing
the gang's escape from the Underworld by knocking
out her own husband.
In reality, she wouldn't have even been there,
and they would've had a much harder time getting
out.
While the movies are controversial among fans
of the books, we've got to give the Percy
Jackson films props for showcasing quite a
bit of disability representation.
In fact, characteristics we'd associate with
disabilities are some of the primary identifiers
that mark a demigod.
Percy has been told that he suffers from ADHD
and dyslexia because his brain is hardwired
for a drastically different world than the
high school landscape of required reading
and standardized tests, making it seem like
he has dysfunctions in a place he wasn't made
for.
The "impulsivity" attributed to ADHD is actually
a manifestation of his combat reflexes, and
the confusion that arises when he tries to
read English results from his natural predisposition
toward reading a notoriously difficult language.
Grover and Chiron both have physical disabilities
in their disguised human forms, as well, and
these two mask underlying strengths and unique
abilities.
Chiron's wheelchair is a camouflaging vessel
for the magnificent horse portion of his centaur
body, and Grover's crutches allow him to mask
the fact that he, as a satyr, has goat legs
that serve him well as Percy's protector.
Percy's entire introduction to the demigod
world is based around the ideas that there's
more to life than meets the eye and that there's
a profound strength of character hiding in
anyone.
When it comes to being sensitive to individuals
of diverse backgrounds, the terminology that
Percy learns to apply to the demigod world
deals with similar issues to that of human
discourse.
He learns the proper way of addressing and
referring to certain "demi-graphics," so to
speak, with the help of his best friend and
guide, Grover, a satyr.
Apparently, "protector" duties include making
sure your charge doesn't say anything that
will get him into trouble, which makes sense
when the wrath of mythical creatures is involved.
It's also just something that good friends
do for each other — hold each other accountable
for using oppressive or offensive language.
One of the first suggestions that Grover offers
relates to his own identity, when he informs
Percy that the "politically correct" term
for a half-man, half-goat is a satyr.
Grover apprises his friend of the proper language
in other scenarios as well.
For example, the preferred way to refer to
a cyclops, we learn, is "ocularly challenged."
In the series, we meet the children of various
gods, and these immortal progeny share similar
characteristics with their classical parents
— traits that younger audiences might not
be familiar with.
For example, Clarisse — an antagonist turned
ally of Percy's in Sea of Monsters – is
a daughter of Ares, which is part of where
she gets the aggression and competitive spirit
that initially makes her such a bitter rival.
Ares' children are pretty formidable in general.
In The Lightning Thief, during the infamous
game of "capture the flag" where the son of
Poseidon first proves his mettle, Luke Castellan
warns Percy:
"Sons of Ares, watch out."
This alludes to the offspring of the god of
war and their inherently violent nature.
The daughters of Aphrodite, the goddess of
love, have also clearly inherited some personality
traits from their mother.
Living together in the house under her name,
they behave like a sorority, spending their
time tanning, flirting, and throwing parties.
Allusions like this to the personality traits
of the gods are a little more subtle than,
say, the son of Poseidon being able to heal
himself with water.
Something odd is going on at the Lotus Casino
in Las Vegas, but only older viewers would
understand the true nature of the lotus flower
cookies that Percy and his friends can't seem
to get enough of.
These addictive, brightly colored sweets represent
something much darker.
The way the teenagers behave after consuming
them and the effects they have on the user's
mood, intellect, and the passage of time render
them a clear reference to party drugs and
narcotics.
The delicacies take their inspiration from
the myth of the Lotus-Eaters, which describes
a tribe of people encountered by Odysseus
on his famous quest, people who offered the
hero and his crew a mysterious plant that
caused them to drift into a state of mindless
bliss outside of time.
This is certainly what happens to Percy, Annabeth,
and Grover in Las Vegas, a city synonymous
with indulgence and excess.
Mr. D — as the attendees at Camp Half-Blood
call Dionysus, the god of wine, madness, and
parties — is the newly appointed camp director
in Sea of Monsters.
This position comes as part of a punishment
Zeus whipped up to get back at his son for
going against the bro code and pursuing a
dryad Zeus had a fancy for.
But the worst of Dionysus' punishment was
the fact that every time he attempted to pour
himself a glass of wine, it turned into water
in his cup.
In response to his curse, he comments that
Christians have a guy who can do that trick
in reverse, a reference to Jesus turning water
into wine in the Bible.
Not only can he not drink any wine, he can't
use his powers to grow grapes for wine, either.
In the books, it's hinted that a prior period
of punishment caused the Prohibition era,
which is also a decidedly adult allusion.
Numerous nods to the real world exist in this
series in addition to Biblical and mythological
references, and it's likely that they pass
right over children.
For instance, kids probably don't notice the
Maserati in which Percy and his friends escape
from the Lotus Casino.
And they probably won't know that the trident
logo for the luxury car brand was, in fact,
based on Percy's father — or at least his
Roman counterpart, Neptune, and the fountain
dedicated to his likeness in the company's
home city of Bologna, Italy.
Another motor vehicle from The Lightning Thief
carries its own special significance.
When the heroes get off their bus amidst the
sounds of AC/DC's "Highway to Hell," the front
of the bus indicates that it's bound for Atlantic
City.
As you may know, Atlantic City has a hellish
reputation among many adults, and is negatively
portrayed in numerous films and shows.
The camera tracks quickly to close in on the
suave ruler of the Underworld, so quickly
that we almost miss it, but eagle-eyed fans
have pointed out that Hades can be seen in
possession of a Gibson SG guitar when we first
meet him in his palace.
This bright red axe is the same type of guitar
as Angus Young's, the lead guitarist of AC/DC.
One of the band's most famous songs is "Highway
to Hell," which for Hades would simply be
the highway home.
The god's persona in the film rocks pretty
hard, as well, from the unruly curls and goatee
to the leather bracelet and aesthetically
ripped black sleeves.
Even more fittingly, the logo of the iconic
rock band features a lightning bolt where
the forward slash would be -- a nod to Zeus'
lightning bolt, which Percy is accused of
stealing in The Lightning Thief.
If The Lightning Thief did a good job with
disability representation, Sea of Monsters
built on that legacy by showcasing the difficulty
of growing up and the insidious nature of
impostor syndrome.
That's when the sufferer believes that they're
inadequate and experiences exaggerated doubt
about their achievements despite evidence
of success.
Percy actually says out loud that he sometimes
doesn't believe he actually did the things
he was praised for.
This lack of belief is actually a symptom
of severe imposter syndrome.
For Percy to say it in such clear terms is
surely comforting to high achievers who suffer
from this illusive mental ailment.
The Mist is a magical force that prevents
mortals -- and sometimes demigods, if it's
strong enough -- from seeing gods, monsters,
and other supernatural entities by disguising
them as something from the mortal world.
For example, such magic is at work disguising
Chiron's centaur body as a wheelchair.
In order to allow him to travel seamlessly
with the group of demigods in Sea of Monsters,
Annabeth procures a spray bottle of Mist that
artificially disguises Tyson, making him look
like a human with two eyes rather than a cyclops.
Hilariously, the side effects listed on the
bottle are a joke at the expense of medication
commercials that spout off a slew of side
effects that are sometimes so contradictory
that they do the opposite of what the medicine
itself is supposed to do.
"Side effects may include handsomeness, headache,
self esteem, and low self-esteem"
Sea of Monsters builds upon the deep discussion
of its predecessor by exploring Annabeth's
prejudice against cyclopes.
Over the course of the film, Annabeth makes
her animosity toward Percy's half-brother,
Tyson — as well as cyclopes in general — very
apparent.
However, we don't really learn why until later
in the story when she opens up about how it
was a cyclops who took the life of her friend,
Thalia, years ago.
To complicate matters further, one of the
biggest obstacles in the film's storyline
is yet another cyclops, from whom they must
rescue Grover, as well as the magical Golden
Fleece.
The circumstances make it very easy for Annabeth
to cling to her personal prejudice, given
that the cyclopean threat to their mission
only serves to reinforce it.
Despite this, however, Annabeth undergoes
a personal journey in tandem with the physical
one, a transformation that holds a lesson
for viewers of all ages.
She gradually learns to dismantle her discriminatory
paradigms and behaviors against cyclopes,
finally acknowledging that it's destructive
to make assumptions about and harbor aggression
toward an entire group of people.
The Gray Sisters — Anger, Wasp, and Tempest
— make their first appearance in Sea of
Monsters, sharing only one eye between them.
This deficiency automatically makes the trio
an ideal slapstick choice to drive a supernatural
taxicab.
As a result, we got a lot of inside jokes
and references thanks to these siblings.
For example, Annabeth announces their vessel
as a Chariot of Damnation, prompting Grover
to reply that it looks like a New York City
cab.
Annabeth retorts, "Same difference," which
is sure to get a chuckle out of any adult
who's taken a bad cab ride.
The sisters also bemoan a familiar mortal
woe — that of a terrible driver's license
picture.
But while our unflattering photos typically
amount to a washed-out face or an awkward
blink, the crime committed by the Graeae's
portrait is much more offensive.
And if you look closely with your own eyes,
however many you have, it also looks like,
from the suspiciously serpentine hair, the
bobblehead on the dashboard is a likeness
of Medusa.
In mythology, the Graeae are the ones who
give the hero Perseus the information he needs
to kill Medusa, by beheading her.
Hermes works for the UPS Store.
That's pretty fitting for the "herald of the
gods," who worked as a messenger and courier
for Mount Olympus and was also the bringer
of good luck and god of wealth, trade, travel,
and language.
The portrayal by Nathan Fillion in Sea of
Monsters captures a subtle blend of matter-of-factness
and mischief that only the deftest of gods
could pull off.
As the god of numerous ubiquitous things,
it's fitting that many of Hermes' artifacts
show up as widely used symbols even today.
We can recognize his winged feet in the Goodyear
logo, as the company thought that the god
Mercury -- who is the Roman version of Hermes
-- held many of the qualities they wanted
their company to be known for.
And honestly, the god of trade and commerce
was a great choice to represent the tire company.
Hermes' staff is also widely used as a symbol
in the United States, representing medicine,
which is definitely a field in which we want
the bringer of good luck on our side.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.